Okay, let's go next to our caller from the
four oh five area code caller from four oh
five.
Uh, what's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hey John.
Hey, how you doing?
Good.
Oh, I'm a heavy breathers, so, okay, here
we go.
Um, so you were talking like a lot the past
couple of weeks about how it's really important
for us to get the right press with a well,
whoever we is so that they can nominally the
court judge, I mean the justice that we want.
I have maybe a bad question here, but then
there's, this gives the American economy.
But anyway, so I thought that just the politics
plays a lot with, uh, the Supreme Court justice
be nominated by the president.
Is there like a no vote options that anyone
has ever considered with, for example?
Uh, and like it no harm, no foul scenario.
This supreme pretty justice with full drove
voting.
It looked like everything from city to stay
to present light.
Well voting out all four of in lieu of the
Supreme Court justice position.
Is that like a, a whore?
I know it's, I mean it's against democracy.
Let me interrupt for a second.
I don't know what you're talking about and
it sounds like you're pressing, I'm curious,
are you doing something else in addition to
doing this call right now?
No, I just let my,
Oh, okay.
So you're saying I have no idea what you're
saying.
You're saying it's who doesn't get to vote
and for what?
In relation to the supreme.
Okay, let's, I'm sorry.
Um, whichever judge is nominated.
Yeah, the president.
Yes.
Could we have what?
I got myself away from the phone a little
bit, so maybe that's better.
Um, is there like a no vote option?
Like no harm, no foul.
What does that mean?
Hey, who vote?
What do you mean no vote?
Who Do, who get little court justice themselves?
The court justice votes for themselves to
get or not get out?
I'm sorry.
Okay.
So the president nominates the court justice
and the court justice obviously has a bias
voting like every single one of us.
So they're nominated by the president that
they're in Midwest, right?
Yes.
So could there be a no harm, no foul, like
a no bill option for court justice once they
accept the job
dope or no?
They have to get confirmed.
And then who gets to vote?
No.
And for what?
John?
I'm sorry.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm going to let you go.
I got 30 people holding here, but I don't,
I just, I don't know.
No harm.
No foul.
I don't know what you mean.